welcome to this video playing taffy on
time from italy and let's let's do
something something different Chuck
benoni check benoni whatever let's see
him not you fault okay yeah try to own
he lost that surprise H was designed to
irritate white a bit and down here he
didn't react in any way surprisingly now
i have from some play on the dark
squares I intend to play Bishop g5 if
possible on g4 at Bishop age for check
so we cannot really kick the light yeah
okay I should take of course let's see
y'all might be five is a bit of an
annoyance let's get rid of this idea
okay castled long I had intended this
anyway Queen f6 to h6 activating the
Queen on get it exchanged I don't want
the Queen trait after my dark squared
bishop has been exchanged I think
strategically speaking I have a fine
position okay he's intending bit up to
age three mmm interesting
no but I can I i will have g form and I
wonder about something different though
I wonder about this move this I could
have played instead of queen of six as
well at least I could have considered it
the ideas after capture capture on b5
this 80 s hanging ok green h6 this was
clear anyway if he plays a g4 let's say
take rook takes g4 I'm interesting hmm
this is an interesting news
huh hmm not sure if I want to I want to
take here okay at first kick the night
my idea is to free the bishop so that
after a capture I can play Bishop g4 but
of course on should reform it can just
take now hmm
understand maybe Knight f6 back yeah
just just just drop back intending
Knight g4 and attacking e4 so that you
cannot easily play Bishop h3 an
interesting a strategical position not
sure what you should do maybe get rid of
the spin we didn't do that interesting
yeah I thought 94 this is quite quite
powerful actually I thought attacking it
and then I think he basically has sued
to take now
yeah maybe can click in the tomb maybe
yeah maybe really kinky do what's a bit
strange this math but nowhere don't see
why it should work I also have of course
a 5 in 4k decided to to capture
yeah now he's got a hard time too yeah I
can I actually am able to take it and I
will so it's a good opportunity to get
rid of the night so that we get this
ideal um mind a piece distribution for
me a night against the bishop on h3a for
if I they formed as a substantial idea
now with the sacrificial ideas even on
see form yeah yeah yeah yeah this is the
only possible counter play the question
is f6 all mod f six or just taking it if
i take it in my play Bishop to e6 at
some point so not sure I come on let's
see let's play it safe okay
I want to prevent a rook h7 of course if
you would have played it immediately
then I could have taken ruka jade and g6
then then this point this point is
dropping off yeah this could be a draw
maybe no but I'm invading now it snowed
wrong course not i also have a form
ok
the question is wow really check this I
wasn't a one hundred percent sure what
to do if he stays put if I should um if
I should take on v3 or play a three the
snow looks are completely lost the boat
both phones here B and C porn are too
strong okay let's let's check I can this
wasn't wasn't even the best best move
probably
okay Mike and I can do that check and no
c 3 okay is it okay come on keep it
cubix angle this is white worth it
sometime this is these I get a four and
then an opening endgame yeah this was an
interesting strategical position around
here he probably gave me too much too
much strategically this move i think is
too much you should true shoot of course
take on age six now instead of letting
me take but yeah this is this is a
difficult position maybe I should take
it so not so clear to me of course
taking has got the big advantage that it
keeps the position an open forum
possible invasion of my king it is very
closed after after f6 but I wasn't sure
if he may be gets in something like that
and how maybe this it is just an old no
problem this kind of ideas looked a bit
a bit annoying to me but I'm probably
too quick am yeah I'm too cool it's not
a problem I mean you can click and play
a move like that but it's no threat
really yeah okay still an interesting
game thanks for watching